wollte mich mit diesem besuch
prototypisch für ein gesundheitsamt
einfach bei allen gesundheitsämtern der
bundesrepublik deutschland bedanken und
mich gleichzeitig über die arbeit der
gesundheitsämter noch einmal im
besonderen informieren
wir wissen alle die öffentlichen
gesundheitsämter der öffentliche
gesundheitsdienst hat in dieser pandemie
in der bekämpfung dieser pandemie eine
zentrale rolle bekommen und in diesem
zusammenhang ist es von entscheidender
bedeutung dass die gesundheitsämter gut
arbeiten das tun sie die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter dass sie
uns sagen wenn sie verstärkt werden
müssen darüber haben wir eben auch
gesprochen
sie haben zusätzliche unterstützung
bekommen wir haben die scouts wir haben
auf der anderen seite auch die
bundeswehr die gegebenenfalls bereit ist
unterstützung zu leisten und insofern
ist das also eine ganz wichtige stelle
an der sich entscheiden wird ob wir bei
neuinfizierten alle kontakte auch
wirklich nachvollziehen können
insofern war das heute für mich ein sehr
sehr wichtiges gespräch ich sag noch mal
ein herzliches dankeschön
und ich kann ihnen sagen da arbeiten
engagierte menschen die werden diese
arbeit schaffen und wo verstärkung
notwendig ist werden wir sie geben
zusammen mit den ländern
was mir allerdings sehr wichtig ist ist
noch einmal darauf aufmerksam zu machen
dass wir jetzt in eine neue phase der
pandemie kommen und dass es jetzt
notwendig sein wird dass wir bei all den
lockerungen auch wirklich sicherheit
haben dass die menschen sich an die
grund- gebote halten also abstand
mundschutz tragen mit nasenschutz
aufeinander rücksicht nehmen das ist
ganz wichtig tja so weit also die
kanzlerin die den gesundheitsämtern in
deutschland heute gedankt hat für ihre
arbeit herr professor cronenberg kommen
wir noch mal darauf zu sprechen was wir
eben schon angesprochen haben und zwar
auf die kompetenz der kanzlerin für den
fall dass es mehrere landkreise mehrere
kommunen gibt in denen die
infektionsrate höhe
als 50 personen